[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
ومساع الاستئناف الملاحه
العثور على صندوق الاسود للطائره
الايطاليه المنكوبه لكن لا مال في وجود
ناجي
تظاهرات مرتقبه الايرانيين امام البرلمان
الاوروبي لتصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
ارهابيه
روسيا تعلن اسقاط مسيره فوق ميناء في
القرمورات مشتركه روسيه بلا روسيه فى مصر
حتى توقفت حركه الملاحه بشكل كامل في مضيق
البوسفور بعد جنوح سفينه شحن قادم
اوكرانيا الى اسطنبول ما ادى الى اغلاق
حركه المرور في المضيق الحيوي لاسباب
امنيه بحسب ما افاد مراسل العربيه وارسلت
السلطات التركيه فرق الانقاذ الى مكان
الحادث لسحب السفينه التي يبلغ طولها 100
142 متر
اكلت السلطات العثور على الصندوق الاسود
للطائره المحطمه والتي راح ضحيتها 10 قتله
وقالت ماندو انا مسجل الصوت قمره القياده
ومسجل بيانات الرحله في حاله جيده وسيتم
الكشف عن تفاصيل اكثر حول حادث الماساوي
لساعه طوال يصطف السوريون في طوابير لا
تكاد تنتهي بالقرب من محطه الوقود اسعار
المواصلات في تزايد مستمر مع استمرار غلاء
الوقود مصانع اغلقته ومكاتب اداريه تلحق
بها لتوفير الطاقه التي اصبحت نادره كل
هذا يحدث في ظل لاتمه الاقتصاديه خانقه
والسبب تقيد ايران لتوريد النفط الرئيسي
لسوريا الحالي في المنهكي منذ اكثر من عقد
ضلت ايرات تستخدم النفط المخفض كورقه
لتوسيع نفوذها في سوريا
ان هذا النفوذ اخذوا فيه انحسار بعدما
تدخلت عن احد بعد ما دخلت اذا عن حالتها
اي سوريا في ازمه طاحنه والاقتصاد
الايراني المتعثر الصحيفه الامريكيه اعاقه
قدره ايران على امداد الفرثائها بالنفط
رخيص الصحيفه اشارت الى تصريحات المتحدث
باسم مصدرين النفط في ايران حيث قال نعاني
ضغوطن ولا يوجد سبب لبيع نفطر سوريا
باسعار مخفضه
يا ايران مشاهدينا حيث لا تزال السلطات
تواصل عمليات الاعتقال التي توصف
بالتعسفيه في حقوق الانسان حيث اتوقنت
النشطه الاجتماعيه في مجال حقوق المراه
الطفل
الالكترونيه
ادت الى تشنجات عصبيه بين النساء السجينات
وتعرضت زاد للسجن اثناء الاحتجاجات
المتواصله في البلاد منذ اربعه اشهر بسبب
مقتل الفتاه الايراني
من قبل من قبل ما يعرف بشرطه الاخلاق انا
ذاكر
هذا وقالت وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه ان محكمه
الثوره بمدينه ساري الواقعه شمال البلاد
حكمت بالاعدام ثلاث مرات على المتطهر
الشعب جواد روحي الاحكام الثلاثه جاءت
بتهم الرده والفساد في الارض والمحاربه
هذا وكانت السلطات اعتقلت جواد روحي
البالغ من العمر سته وثلاثين عاما في
سبتمبر الماضي وسبق ان كتبت لجنه متابعه
اوضاع المعتقلين في ايران ان جواد روحي
الاعترافي اثناء احتجاجه بدوره اعلن محمد
صادقاري رئيس قضاه مازن دهان صدور حكم على
جوابات روحي بالاعدام في المحكمه
الابتدائيه بتهمه الفساد في الارض مضيفا
انا المتهم لم يقدموا حاميا في مرحله
المحاكمه وتم اختياره حامل من قبل المحكمه
هذا امي المتوقع ان تنظم اليوم تظاهره
حاشده امام من البرلمان الاوروبي في مدينه
الفرنسيه وذلك بعد دعوات اطلقها عدد من
ناشطين والسياسيين الايرانيين في الخارج
لنضال لمعارضه النظام الايراني بهدف
مطالبه الاتحاد الاوروبي وجميع الحكومه
الاوروبيه بتصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني
كمامه الارهابيه وتاتي هذه المساعي على
خلفيه جهود المبذوله في الاونه الاخيره من
قبل من نواب البرلماني الاوروبي وبرلمانات
الوطنيه الاوربيه
التي اسقطها الحرس الثوري في ظهران مطلع
عام 2020 يعني انضمام الى هذه التظاهرات
مطالبين ايضا الحكومات الاوروبيه بترضي
سفراء النظام الايراني
رجح ناشطون ان تفقد العديد من شرائح
المجتمع الايراني المحدوده الدخل المحدود
الدخل القدره على الوصول لخدمه الانترنت
النشطون ارجعوا ذلك لارتفاع الكبير في
مبالغ الاشتراكات الشهريه في تطبيقات
تجاوز الحد في التي تتجاوز القيود التي
فرضها سلطات على الانترنت قبل ثلاثه اشهر
هذا ويوصل النظام الايراني انتاج سياسه
الاعدام في حق العديد من الشخصيات البارزه
وهذه المره مع المواطن البريطاني الايراني
علي رضا اكبر
بعد اعدامي علي رضا اكبر المثير للجدل
وردود الفعل الغربيه المهدده تظهر تطورات
الاحداث في ايران ان عمليه الاعدام ما هي
الا مقدمه لصنع متوقع في هيكل النظام
الايراني
وليس ادله على ذلك ما شرب من حديث اكبر مع
القاضي المكلف بمحاكمته
فواحده من التهم التي اعدم اكبر بسببها هي
حصوله على معلومات سريه عن الدوله من امين
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علي شمساني
مقابله زجاجه عطر وقميص
وهنا كان سؤال اكبري البدايه للقاضي اذا
كان شمخاني سرب هذه المعلومات اليه فلماذا
لا يحاكم معي
لكن رد القاضي كان مفاجئا اذ قال للشاكي
ليس لدي القوه لاستدعاء شمخاني لكنني
سادمرك انت
طبعا كل هذا بالاضافه لما تعرض له اكبر من
تعذيب لفتره طويله انتزعت خلالها
اعترافاته قصرا
السؤال الذي يدور الان بين دوائر
المتابعين هل كان اكبر هو الهدف امشي ام
خان نفسه
ايران انترناشونال قالت وفقا لوفائك حصلت
عليها من داخل الحرس الثوري ان الاطاحه
بشمخاني هي الهدف الاكبر مما حدث لاكبر
وحتى الشبكات التابعه للحرس الثوري على
تلغرام تناولت معلومات عن اقاله الرجل لكن
المتحدث باسم المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
نفى ذلك تماما
بل ان الحديث امتد الى خليفته القادمه وتم
التركيز على وزير الداخليه احمد وحيد
باعتباره صاحب اكبر الفرق
ويرى معارضون ان النظام قد يكون في مرحله
محاسبه من يعتقد انهم خذوه خلال موجه
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
الى التدخل لاخماد الاحتجاجات
ووعد بالسعيد لتقديم مزيد من الحريه
وتحقيق بعض مطالب المحتجدين هذا النهج لم
يرق لصقور النظام الذين راوا على الدوام
ان القبضه الحديديه هي الحل لعلاج كل
المشكله
قال حاكم مدينه
البحر الاسود
من جهه اخرى اكد الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي السلطان بيرج ان الدول الغربيه
تدرس اوكرانيا شحنات جديده من الاسلحه
الثقيله وقال صوره سنبر لصحيفه المانيا
قبل اجتماع هذا الاسبوع في قاعده
الجويه لمجموعه الاتصال الدفاع عن
اوكرانيا قال ان التعاهدات الاخيره بتسليم
اسلحه الثقيله مهمه لاوكرانيا وستكون خلال
مستقبل القريب مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى ان
المرحله الحاليه من الحرب تعد حاسمه
اذا مشاهدينا كما ذكرنا تواصل الدول
الغربيه تقديما دعامها العسكري الى
اوكرانيا
مع روسيا ومن اسلحه دفاعيه الى اخرى
هجوميه طول الغرب دعمه بالمعدات والاليات
العسكريه كان اخرها دبابات بريطانيه وفقا
لموقع لكي اشار الموقع الى دبابات تشالنجر
بريطانيه التي لم يستقبل مثلها من قبل
وسترسل بريطانيا اربع 10 من دباباتها الى
جانب دعم مدفع اضافي لاوكرانيا اما فرنسا
فسترسل دبابات من طراز ار سي 10 اي ام اكس
وهي مصممه مهام الاستطلاع وبفضل بالفعلها
القويه وحركتها السريعه فهي قادره على
تقديم الدعم الناري والتدخل العسكري ومن
جانب الداعم الاكبر الولايات المتحده فقد
قررت ارسال مركبه المشاه القتاليه والتي
استخدمت في العراق
عدد من دبابات اليوبارت المانيه الصنع
مملوكه لبولندا وتستلمها كيف فور موافقه
برلين الى جانب مدرعات ماردر المزوده
بمعدلات الرؤيه الليليه ومكثف الصور
والتصوير الحراريه ايضا
العمود الفقري لقوه الدبابات في الجيش
البريطاني وهي واحده من اربع دبابات
قتاليه رئيسيه طورتها دول حلف الناتو لخوض
الحروف فهل ستقدر هذه الدبابات على مواجهه
دبابه تي 9 الروسيه احدى افضل دبابات
العالم من حيث الحمايه والتدريع في ساحه
المعركه باوكرانيا مشاهدينا طول دبابات
تشالنجر 2 يتجاوز الاحد 10 مترا ووزنها
اثنين و60 طنا ونصف دبابه ثقيله الحركه
سرعتها تصل الى 59 كلم في الساعه ويصل
مداها الى 450 كلم اما تي 9 فطولها وطولها
هيكلها اقل من سبعه امتار ووزنها اخاف
بكثير ويصل الى نحو ثمانيه واربعين طنا
بالذخائر والافراد قدره عاليه على
المناوره مع سرعه قصوى تصل الى 70 كم في
الساعه بينما يصل مداها الى 500 كلم
تشالنجر 2 مشاهدين الدبابه مصممه لمهاجمه
الدبابات الاخرى وتدميرها تحتوي على دروع
ثقيله ومدفع رايسي من عيار 22 ملم باثنين
وخمسين قذيفه بالاضافه طبعا لمدفعين اخرين
بمقدار اربعه الاف طلقه فيما المدفع
الرئيسي للدبابه الروسيه فهو من عيار
125 ملم كمان نشاهد هنا اجمالي الطلقات مع
مدفعين اخرين يبلغ الفين و 2340 طلقه
ومجهز بصواريخ موجهه مداها خمسه كيلومترات
تتميز تي 9 بالنظام قليل التحكم في اطلاق
النار هنا دبابه باستطاعتها البحث عن
الاهداف وتعقب هذه الاهداف في وضع الثبات
او الحركه ليلا او نهارا ايضا كانت الظ
تشويه بالعوده مشاهدينا الى تشالنجر هي
مصممه لعبور التضاريس المفتوحه
وتمثلها بذلك الدبابه الروسيه ذات القدره
العاليه على اجتياز الموانع الطبيعيه
الى 35لا وقال رئيس الاوكراني ان مصيره
اكثر من 30 شخص في المبنى الذي دمره صاروخ
اطلقته روسيا ما زال مجهولا رغم استمرار
عمليات الانقاذ
مشاهدينا نلتقي الان الى القدس ومراسم
تولي هرسي هاليفي رئاسه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلف لاوي الفخافي الذي تنتهي
مهامه في هذا الموسم اليوم بعد ان استمر
في منصبه اكثر من خمسه 35 عاما هذه الكلمه
لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الحسنه
خلال السنوات الاربعه الاخيره
[موسيقى]
اربع سنين
مواجهه الاختبارات
[موسيقى]
مشاهيرنا بالعوده مره اخرى الى الملف
الروسيه الاوكراني تجري روسيا وبيلاروسيا
اليوم مناورات جويه مشتركه وصفاتها
بدفاعيه وللتحضير لصد اي هجوم محتمل واوضح
مجلس الامن بلا روسي ان تدريبات المشتركه
مع روسيا ذات طبيعه دفاعيه بحته واعلن
مجلس مستعده لاي اعمال الوصفتها
بالاستفزازيه من جانب اوكرانيا
لا مشاهدينا الى احاديث جنوح سفينه في
مضيق البوسفور وتعليق حركه الملاحه معنا
امين اسطنبول وراس العربي كله اهلا بك
زيدان هل بدات عمليات التعويم السفينه
نعم لا تزال محاولات السلطات التركيه لجر
هذه السفينه بعيدا عن المكان الذي جنحت
الي نحن كما تشاهدون الان في الخلفيه وعلى
الشاشه مباشره هذه هي السفينه التي جناحات
وكانت قادمه من اوكرانيا هناك ثلاث سفن او
ثلاث قاطرات للشحن تحاول جر السفينه
ومحاوله تعويم السفينه ومن ثم ابعادها عن
هذا المكان الذي جنحت اليه تقريبا ليس
قريبا حركه الملاحه توقفت تماما همم على
جانبي او في الاتجاهين في مضيق البوسفور
سواء من البحر الاسود او من بحر
توقفت الحركه تماما قبل قليل وادي اسطنبول
تحدث عن هذا الموضوع وقال ان السفينه حدثت
فيها عطل في موجه القياده لذلك همم
لذلك جنحت وتحاول السلطات جاهده ل- همم
لابعادها عن هذا المكان بحسب اسطنبول ان
هذه السفينه ليست همم محمله همم او ما رشح
او ما فهمناه من بيان والاسطنبول هذه
السفينه ليست محمله بمشتقات نفطيه اموال
نفطيه لذلك كما ذكرت في همم قبل قليل في
النشره السابقه ربما البعض يرجح ان هذه
السفينه ربما تكون محمله بالحبوب لكن حتى
الان لا توجد معلومات اكيده حول حموضه هذه
السفينه السلطات لم تعلن همم السفينه
بالضبط جنحت في الساعه السابعه والنصف همم
تم جروح السفينه همم الى شاطئ بيكوز همم
عند مرورها من مضيق الوصفور من البحر
الاسود وهمم كانت متجهه الى بحر ايجه
قادمه اوكرانيا في تمام الساعه السابعه
والنصف بها التوقيت المحلي الرابعه والنصف
فجرا بتوقيت جرينتش همم جناحات هذه
السفينه ومنذ ذلك الحين اين تحدث تقريبا
عن همم اربعه ساعات همم ما زالت المحاولات
مستمره من قبل السلطات التركيه لحل هذه
المشكله زيدان
ان المدى الزمن الذي يمكن من خلاله اعاده
تعيين هذه السفينه
لن تعطي مدى زمن معين السلطات التركي لكن
همم توقف مضيق البوسفور كما شاهدنا اا على
الشاشه قبل قليل وهو يمثل مشكله بحد ذاتها
سواء لالسلطات التي او الاداره التي تدير
هذا المضيق او حتى للسفن العالقه على
جانبي المضيق بانتظار الدخول اي تاخير في
هذا الموضوع ربما سيسبب احراجا اولا لي
السلطات تركيا وايضا مشاكل في موضوع الشحن
وصول السفن في الموعد المحدد للوصول
بالعموم هو مضيق البوسفور بالاساس مضيق
مزدحم وتنتظر السفن همم مده معينه حتى يتم
السماح لها بعبور المضيق همم بثلاثه لكن
مثل هذه الحوادث يمكن ان تعيق الملاحه
اكثر واكثر ذلك السلطات تحاول استعجال او
المحاوله في اسرع وقت لحال هذه المشكله
وتعويم السفينه مجددا نعم شكرا لك امير
اسطنبول كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل انباء
عن انطلاق محادثات ليبيه جديده بين حفتر
والمنفي وعقيل صالح في القاهره
الروح سفينه القادمه من اوكرانيا ومسائل
الاستئناف في الملاحه
العثور على صندوق الاسود للطائره
النيباليه المنكوبه لكن لا امال في وجود
ناجين
تظاهرات المرتقبه الايرانيين امام
البرلمان الاوروبي لتصنيف الحرس الثوري
منظمه ارهابيه
روسيا تعلن اسقاط مسيره فوق ميناء في
القرم وبده مناورات مشتركه روسيه بلا
روسيه في مصر
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد
الازرق وقبيله الهوسه اتفاقا ايطاليا لدعم
التعريف السلمي بحضور رئيس مجلس السياده
عبد الفتاح برهان الاتفاق بين اطراف
النزاع في الاقليم شمل اجراءاته وقف
العدائيات والاستجابه للاجراءات فرض هيبه
الدوله وتفعيل مجلس السلام واجراءات تضمن
عوده النازحين ايضا
مكونات اتجهت ارادتها نحو الهدنه بعد
اقتتال خلف المئات من الضحايا والمصابين
اتفاق اقاري للتعايش السلمي يمهد الطريقه
لمؤتمر جامع للصلح بين القبائل
هو خارطه الطريق
لوقف العدايات وهو بيكون ملزم للفراق او
للطرفين انهم ااا يوقفوا
الاغتسال فيما بينهم يجرمن
يتم ائتمان بواسطه مجلس الوزراء حكومه
لتصبح اقليم النيل الازرق اول منطقه يتم
فيها اصدار
ويدخل المتنازعين في هدنه الا ان المخاوف
من عدم صموده بددتها ضمانات الرد الحاسب
الذي تعهدت به القوه المسلحه
اهميه ما جرى اليوم يكمن في
الاتفاق على هدنه محروسه بالقوات المسلحه
وبالحركه والجيش الشعبي وكل المكونات
الامنيه وانها ستتعامل بحسب ااا مع هذه
الهدنه الامنيه بالتالي انا اعتقد ان
هنالك فرصه كبيره في الايام القادمه
للوصول لاتفاق اذا ينفتح المشهد في
الاقليم الاستراتيجي والمحادي لدوله جنوب
السودان واثيوبيا على واقع جديد اثر
المصالحات بين مكوناته الاجتماعيه بعد
اغتال كاد ان يعصف بامني واستقراري
المنطقه باسرها محمد عثمان العربيه اقليم
النيل الازرق مدينه التمازين
في كلمه له بمدينه الدمازين اقليم مني
الازرق طلب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
عبد الفتاح برهان ان تبقى القوات المسلحه
وداعمه لديمقراطيه وخاليه من جماعه
الاخوان واليساريين على حد تعبيره
للوهله الاولى تشعر انك في قلبي معركه لا
تبقي ولا تذر برا وجوا
غير ان الصوره من قريب في اقليم النيل
الازرق هي لختام مهرجان الرمايه السابع
والخمسين للجيش السوداني بمشاركه مختلف
الوحدات العسكريه وبحضور قائد عام الجيش
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
الذي لم ينفك يرسل رسائل عسكريه وسياسيه
المسلحه قوات محترفه ما عنده علاقه
بالتنظيمات السياسيه ما فيها اخوان ولا
فيها يساريين ولا فيها يمين قوات مسلحه
سودانيه حق السودان هي صمام امان هذا
السودان عشان كذا بنقول نحن والله
ماشيين في التوافق الحصل نحن متوقع انه ما
تم توقيعه من الاتفاق اطاري يخرج هذه
البلاد من وحدته ويوحد شملنا ويحينا عشان
نبني هذا البلد
مهرجان الرمايه في نسخته السابعه والخمسين
حمل رسائله للعسكريين وللمدنيين هنا في
اقليم النيل الازرق الذي يعيش على واقع
التوترات بين مجموعات قبليه
انطلقت في القاهره جوله محادثات جديده بين
القائد العام الجيش الليبي خليفه حفتر
ورئيس المجلس الرئاسي محمد الريفي ورئيس
مجلس النواب عقيل صالح مع عقاد اللجنه
العسكريه المشتركه التي تضم طرفي الصراع
العسكري في البلاد بمدينه سيرت بحضور رئيس
بعثه الامم المتحده عبدالله
وبحسب بما نقل صحيفه الشرق الاوسط عن
مقربين من المسؤولين الثلاثه فقد وصل صالح
الى القاهره في وقت السابقه من مساء السبت
لكنهم امتنعوا عن اصدار اي توضيح لفحوى
المحادثات المشتركه في ما قالت مصادر
مصريه متطابقه للصحيفه للصحيفه ان
الاجتماع
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
مشاهدينا افاده ايضا مراسل العربيه في
ليبيا باستئناف وفدي اللجنه العسكريه 5 +
5 اجتماعي لليوم الثاني والختامي بمقررها
الدائم بمدينه سيرت الليبيه ومن المقرر ان
تستكمل لجنه مباحثاتها حول الانقاط
العالقه وفي مقدمتها خروج المرتزقه
والعناصر الاجنبيه وتوحيد المؤسسه
العسكريه وتتم المباحثات ايضا بحضور
الامين ليبيا عبد الله بعتيلي الذي يحاول
دعم عمل اللجنه خلال المرحله المقبله
مشاهدينا لم يسترك العربيه محمد مسعود
اهلا بكم محمد اجتماع اللجنه العسكريه 5+5
لليوم الثاني يبدا اليوم ماذا ينتظر منه
نعم احمد بالفعل ننتظر فيه وصول الوفدين
من مقر اقامتهم هنا بمدينه سرت في وسط
البلاد لكي يصل الى هذه القاعه من خلفي
الان كما تشاهد مع الساده المشاهدين
لاستئناف اليوم الثاني من مباحثاتهم في
هذه الجوله العاشره بمقر اللجنه هنا
بمدينه سره عدد كبير من الملفات مطروح على
الطاوله هذا الاجتماع
ايضا بحضور السيد عبد الله بتيلي مبعوث
الامم المتحده الى ليبيا الذي تواجد ايضا
ليله الامس هنا في المدينه مع الوفدين
لاستكمال المباحثات والمناقشات في هذا
اليوم الختامين من المفترض ان يصدر بيان
ختامي في نهايه اجتماعات هذا اليوم ظهرت
هذا اليوم او على اقصى تقدير احمد في عصر
هذا اليوم يصدر بها ختامي بالساعه الثانيه
بالتحديد بتوقيت غرينتش الرابيه على
التوقيت المحلي يوضح ابرز ما جرى من توافق
على عديد
ما بين الوفدين الوفدين اللجنه العسكريه
اهم بنود مطروحه في هذا اليوم الثاني
والختام بعد ما كان كل التركيز يوم الامس
منصب على عمل المراقبين المحليين
والدوليين وامكانيه التعاون بين الاثنين
خاصه في مجال مراقبه مواقف اطلاق النار او
حتى تسجيل اي خروقات في الفتره القادمه
ومعالجه الخروقات التي حصلت في الفتره
الماضيه هذا اليوم سوف تتركز المباحثات
على مساله اخراج المرتزقه والعناصر
والقوات الاجنبيه من البلاد بالاضافه الى
تفكيك المجموعات المسلحه وهناك عدد من
التصورات والمقتراحات جهزتها اللجنه
العسكريه وتم توافق عليها ما بين الوفدين
من اجل تقديمها لي المبعوثه الاميه في
انتظار فقط دعم المجتمع الدوري عن طريق
السيد عبد الله والبعثه اليوم لكن هل
تكشفت معلومات حول ما تم تداوله بالامس او
ما تم التوصل اليه بين الفرق او بين اطراف
عفوا
نعم احمد هو يعني هناك صراحه وتيره
متسارعه من الاجتماعات سواء في المسار
السياسي وحتى المسار العسكري وكلاء
الاجتماعيين مرتبطين ببعضهم البعض بدءا من
زياره مدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه السي اي
اي الى ليبيا ولقائه شرقا وغربا باطراف
الفاعله او حتى نتحدث عن هذا الاجتماع في
مساره العسكري والذي يحاول السيد عبد الله
باتيلي احيائهم من جديد او تسريح وتيره
خطوات لتنفيذ كل اتفاق جنيف او اتفاق
اطلاق النار ولكن ما يحدث في العاصمه
المصريه القاهره ليس ببعيده عن ما يحدث
هنا هناك رؤيه يعني اصبحت تتبلور شيئا
المجتمع الدولي وهناك فرصه اخيره تمنح
اللي هي لطراف السياسيه وتحدثنا عن القائد
الدستوريه والوثيقه الدستوريه وضروره
التصويت كلاه المجلسين على اعتماديه
للاصرار بالوصول الى الانتخابات ولكن ما
يدار في خلف الكواليس احمد صلاح احنا هناك
حل ثاني في حال فاشله هذه المفاوضات في
فرصتها الاخيره وربما اجتماع السيد بديري
خلفي في هذه القاعه مع اللجنه العسكريه
هذا الموضوع بشقه الامني والعسكري واجتماع
القاهره يبحثه بشقه السياسي وايضا هناك
ابعاد امنيه بحضور قائد الجيش هناك او حتى
رئيس المجلس الرئاسي لتوحيد الرؤى لتصب في
نتيجه واحده او هدف واحد وهو اجراء
الانتخابات في الفتره القادمه على الاقل
قبل نهايه هذا العام ولكن كده المسارات او
كل المسارات ترتبط ببعضها البعض سياسي او
حتى هذا المسار الذي نتواجد فيه الان من
النصارا التحدث امام لجنه 5+5 مشتركه هو
همم الحفاظ على اصدقاء الاوضاع وعدم
العوده مره اخرى الى مربع الاحترام بين
الفرق همم كيف ينظر من من جهه الراي العام
الى
قدره اللجنه على تحقيق هذه الاهداف
ما نرصده في الشارع صراحه يعني احمد هناك
ثقه كبيره لدى المواطنين شرقا وغربا وحتى
هنا في وسط البلاد فيما تقوم به اللجنه من
اعمال كون ان الصراع في السابق كان صراعا
مسلحا بامتياز لا صوت يعلو فوق سوا يعني
فوهات البنادق ما بعد التوقيع اتفاق جنيف
في العام 20 20 وفي نهايته بالتحديد كان
لهذه اللجنه دور كبير في عمليه وقف اطلاق
النار وتحول الصراع الى صراع سياسيه هذه
النقطه بالتحديده لا يزال الشارع الليبي
يتذكرها اللجنه وتحسب اللجنه في انتظار
استكمال باقي مهامها بها هناك عدد كبير من
المهام ابرزه وقفه اطلاق النار هو ايقاف
الحرب وثانيه هو فتح الطريق الساحلي الذي
كان شريان حياه ما بين مناطق الغرب والشرق
وسط البلاد وناجحه اللجنه في تجاوزتين
النقطتين وبعدها تم اجراء عدد كبير من
العمليات اكثر من سبع عمليات لتبادل
المحتجزين والاسرى ما بين الطرفين وكل هذه
النقاط تمثل ارضيه صلب او ارضيه قوه
لاعمال اللجنه في انتظار فقط ما تبقى من
النقاط وابرزها عمليه اخراج المرتزقه
والاجانب كونه ترتبط به المجتمع الدولي من
جهه او حتى بالتوافق السياسي المفقود
والمنشود حتى اللحظه
على مراسل العربيه محمد مسعود تحيه محمد
اكول هذه التوضيحات
مشاهدينا بالعوده مره اخرى الى القدس
وتولي رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي الجديد
مهام مصيبه معنا مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي
اهلا بك زياد ماذا نعرف عن رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي الجديد وعن خلفيه ترشيحه لهذا
المصري
بدون ما حدث اليوم في اسرائيل لافته مرتين
المره الاولى لان الرئيس الاركان الجديد
عمليا هو تعيين من وزير الدفاع السابق في
نهايه الحكومه الاسرائيليه السابقه اعينه
وهو عمليا تعيين ليس الغيار الغيار المفضل
لنتنياهو الجنرال في ليبي رغم انه همم
قائد معروف في الجيش الاسرائيلي همم كان
قائد لسلاحا لمظليين كان فائده المنطقه
الجنوبيه وما الى ذلك لتلياهو كان يفضل
مستشاره العسكري السابق جنرال التميمي
ولكن عمليا مضطر الان للتعامل لماذا هذا
الامر مهم اذكره همم حاليا لانه عند ذهاب
مثلا لضرب ايران مهم جدا وحاسم راي رئيس
الاركان في الجيش الاسرائيلي همم في
اسرائيل بانني رغم انه غير مغامر همم
حربيا لكنه يرى بمنظور تاريخي وقد تجاوز
70 همم نفسه كمان يوقف المشروع النووي
الايراني ويضرب المنشات عمليا هذا يعيد
الى الارهاب عام 2018 عندما قرر ذلك فعلا
ولكن من مناعه كان رئيس اركان في اسرائيل
اسمه بالمصادفه همم بني جانس الذي عين هذا
رئيس الاركان الحالي وبالتالي اذا رفض ان
يعطل ذلك ضرب لايران ان كان
لثانيه فعلا يخطط لمثل هذه الضربه في
المستقبل طيب اضافه الى الملف الايراني ما
ابرز التحديات التي تواجه رئيسها كان جديد
وما الذي ينتظره منه الاسرائيلي ايضا
التهديد المباشر عمليا هي الضفه الغربيه
المحتله تحديدا هناك حال غليان هي على
صفيحه ساخن هناك عمليات اطلاق نار وتبادل
واشتباكات يوميا والتقديرات في اسرائيل
بان الامور ذاهبه الى التصعيد ما قد يؤدي
الى اشعال الحرب على قطار غزه التحدي
الاساسي للجنرال الجديد هو قضيه توزيع او
تقسيم وزاره الدفاع وهذه لاول مره في
تاريخ اسرائيل يحدث هذا الامر الان لديه
همم وزيرين ونصف على راسه عمليا وزير
الدفاع جلال ولكن ايضا وزير في وزاره
الدفاع وزير الماليه المسؤول عن الاداره
المدنيه اي البناء للمستوطنين واداره
الشؤون المدنيه في الضفه الغربيه
والوزير الثالث هو الامن القومي عن همم
2000 جندي في الضفه الغربيه اقصد بذلك حرس
الحدود هذا التعقيد غير مسموح عمليا همم
تبارك كيف سيكون
بعد تحدي جدي جدا لهذا الجنرال العمليا
ولاده راينا جلن في الخطاب عندما تحدث هو
ومن نتنياهو قال ان اي خلاف وضغوطات
سياسيه ستقف عندي في اشاره الى الوزيرين
الاخرين ولكن بدون دردشه كما قال نتانيه
ايضا في المؤتمر الصحفي همم ايران تبقى
التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه لاسرائيل وبالنسبه
لزوجها بدون المجد في العام الخامس نعم
شكرا لكم يا القدس وانت معنا مراسل
العربيه زياد حلبي تحياتي زياد
اغاني الاتحاد العامه
التي
تناقش ملامحها خلال الاجتماع
بعد بالشكل الكامل وستحدد محاورها
بالتنسيق مع شركه الاتحاد ومع من سيتحق
لاحقا بها كما رجح الامين العام المساعد
اتحاد الشغل ان تتعلق المحاوله مبادره
الانقاذ بنتائج الانتخابات التشريعيه في
دورها الاول وامكانيه اجراء انتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكرا وتعديل الدستور والقانون
الانتخابي ثم المرور الى الانتخابات
التشريعيه
تعتزم حكومه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اليوم
على مقترحات الجديده لمواجهه الاحتجاجات
ومنح الشرطه سلطات او ساعه لمنع حدوث
اضطرابات خطيره واصدره الحكومه تشريعه
لمعالجه هذا الامر في العام الماضي لكنها
تخطط للمضي قدما في مجموعه جديده من
القوانين تعرف باسم قانون النظام العامه
وتقوم الحكومه بل تقول الحكومه الى
القوانين الجديده في حاله اخبارها ستعني
انه بامكان الشرطه ايقاف الاحتجاجات التي
تصل الى مستوى التخريب بشكل استفاقي اشاره
تقرير الصحفي
البريطانيه الى احتماليه اجراء مصالحه بين
امريكا
بعد نشر مذكرات الامير هاري تحت عنوان
البديل وفقا لتحت عنوان البديل ووفقا
لمصدر المقرر من الامين الامير هاري عفوا
والعائله الملكيه بين المصالح ممكنه وان
كانت تتطلب تجاوز عقبات
من باب المصالحه قد يعود الامير هاري الى
اروقه قصر باكينده لكنها قد تكون عاجله
قبل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث مايو
المقبل وفقا لصحيفه ساندي تايمز
البريطانيه
اجتماعا قد يعقد بينهما في حضور وريث
العرش الامير ويليام خلال الاشهر المقبله
رغبه حقيقيه لجلوس شقيقين مع الملك تشارلز
في غرفه واحده
ومصالحه ممكنه لكن تقف في طريقها عقبات
حسب تقريري تايمز تتطلب المصالحه
والاعتراف باخطاء الماضي من قبل الجميع
وهو ما يحتاج الى مرونه قد يفتقدها هاري
الراغب في الحصول على اعتذار من العائله
الملكيه لزوجته الى جانب المساءله قبل
المصالحه
العقبه الثانيه تتمثل في نيران كتاب
البديل التي جعلت الامير وليام يحترق
داخليا حسب وصف المصدر المقرب من الجانبين
فهل يستطيع وريث العرش الحفاظ على هدوء
بعد تركومات الخلاف مع شقيقه هاري
غياب الثقه المتبادله يظل حاجزا ليس فقط
من اجل اتمام المصالحه ولكن من اجل الجلوس
اولا فبحسب المصادر ينبغي وجود افراد من
الاسره يثق فيهم هاري حتى لا يعتقد انه
يتعرض لكم من ما
عقبه نحو المصالحه يسعى القصر الى تذليلها
وملك يرغب في تهيئه اجواء طبيعيه خلال
مراسم التتويج في مايو المقبل وان لم تهدا
الاجواء فقد تتحول الى مصدر الهاء وتشتيت
وفقا لمقربين من العائله الملكيه
علي السمان العربيه
[تصفيق]
دافع البيت الابيض عن التهامات الرئيس
متعاونون مع وزاره العدل ويقومون بتسليم
كل الوثائق حاله اكتشافها لمكتب المحفوظات
الوطنيه لكن الرئيس التفاصيل
لكنه ينظر بعاصفه سياسيه فمشاكل الرئيس
القانونيه تتراكم بعد الكشف عن وثائق سريه
جديده في بيته ليصل المجموعه الوثائق الى
20 وثيقه بعض المحامين المحافظين يرون بان
بيض في خطر اكبر من الرئيس ترامب الذي
احتفظ بحوالي 300 وثيقه في منتجعه في
مارادو ورفض التعاون مع المحققين
والمحامين والتهمه بعرقله مشرع العداله
والسبب ان الترام ادعى بانه نزع السريه عن
تلك الوثائق امر يخوله الدستور حسب بعض
المحامين المحافظين لكن هناك انقسام في
وجهه النظر القانونيه التي تقول بان هذه
الصلاحيه هي من صلاحيات الكونجرس وليس
الرئيس ومهما كابرا او ثوره حجم الخطر
المحيط ببايدر فهناك مساء الى ق هي وشيكا
في مجلس النواب وهذا قد يؤثر على فرص
الرئيس في الترشح لولايه
رئاسه اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي من هيرسي
هاليفي
الوحده
الذين تسببتم في حياه طبيعيه لاسرائيل
والتربيه الجيده الاخلاق
كثير هذه دوله كادر اليوم
اخلاقي وتكنولوجيا
يوجد هناك
وهناك مهمه مهمه جدا كانت تلين
مشاهده
جدا
[موسيقى]
جمهور اسرائيل
رحله مشتركه وانا اشكرك جميعا
كل من علمني
[تصفيق]
عيوب اخرى
مع فاطمه
الاسواق المنطقه وايضا الاسواق العالميه
في اولى جلسات هذا الاسبوع الصوره متباينه
مؤشر سوق الاسهم السعوديه يكسر حاجز
العشره الاف 1700 نقطه في ضل عدم وجود
اخبار يمكن ان تحرك السوق بشكل كبير ما
عدا اخبار الشركات ولكن القصه الرئيسيه
بالطبع تبقى في موسم اعلان الشركات عن
نتائج اعمالها لا ارقام تذكر اليوم دبي
يضيف حول السفر فصل اثنين في المئه لعل
ابرز خبر سمعناه هي هذه التقارير
الاعلاميه التي تتحدث انه ثلاث شركات
تامين مدرجه في دبي تدرس
نيه اندماجها وتاسيس مؤسسه عملاقه في هذا
القطاع وسوق ابو ظبي على ثبات مؤشر الكويت
يعود للارتفاع مره اخرى بعد السلسله من
التصحيح شهدناها خلال الجلسات الماضيه لا
زالت الشركات القياديه هي التي تقود
الحركه على مؤشر الاول والبورصه القطريه
تتراجع باكثر من واحد في المئه عالميا
اسعار النفط تشهد بعد التصحيح هذه جلسه من
حيث التراجعات بعد ثماني جلسات متتاليه من
حيث الارتفاعات عكست لنا تفاؤل حيل الوضع
في الصين واقتصادها وعوده افتتاحات هذه
الصين وايضا الاعلان الرسمي الذي صدر من
وزاره الصحه هناك الهيئه الصحه تتحدث انه
نسبه الاصابات بيكورونا وصلت للذروه وهذا
الشيء جيد جدا لانه همم بنتوقع نشوف تراجع
في عدد الاصابات التي شهدت تسارع كبير
خلال الفتره الماضيه واخرت من عوده افتتاح
الصين بشكل رسمي اسواق العالميه نشهد فيها
احجام تداولات متواضعه في ظل غياب اليوم
السوق مغلقه هناك ولكن الصوره ايجابيه
ولكن ارتفاعات سابقه متواضعه على الجلسه
الاوروبيه ارقام التضخمات صدرت من همم همم
امريكا يوم الجمعه اعطتنا همم دفعه
ايجابيه لما يمكن ان نتوقع من الفتى الان
السوق يحتسب رفع اسعار الفائده فقط ب 25
نقطه اساس بالشماع فبراير اغلاقات اسيا
اليوم كانت مدعومه بالقوه في الين ضغط على
الاسهم اليابانيه بشكل واضح ولكن الصوره
في باقي الاسواق كانت ايجابيه بفضل الصين
كوزبي اضاف حوالي
0.6% من حيث الارتفاعات وكما ذكرنا لين لا
زال هو العمله الرئيسيه لمراقبها كنا
راينا ليان يتداول عند اعلى مستوى منذ
سبعه اشهر الان بدا يتراجع بعض الشيء
لصالح الدولار
انا اعود معكم برامج الاسواق العربيه نحلل
ابرز اخبار اسواق المال اما الان عوده الى
السوجوهات العربيه واحمد
شكرا لك يا فاطمه مشاهدينا ماشيين مع
الوضع المائي الصعب في الاردن والتغير
المناخي الذي اثر على العديد من المواسم
المطريه قامت الحكومه الاردنيه بتنفيذ
مشاريع الحصاد من خلال استحداث مساحات
وسدود ترابيه لتجميع مياه الامطار في
المناطق الزراعيه واماكن زراعي الاغنام
ازمه ثبت بجفاف في معظم السدود وتصحرها
وليوم بعد الاعتماد عالميه الامطار في
بدايه هذا الموسم التي اعادت بعض السدود
لوضعها الطبيعي
هنا الجفاف يدق ناقوس الخطر قاع السدود
المائيه الاردنيه وصله حد التصحر اماني
والمشهد يعكس وضع ازمه البلاد المائيه
المشهد في السدود التي وصلت نسبه المياه
فيها ما يقارب 75 مليون متر مكعب
الوجهه سد الموجب الذي يعتبر احد اهم
السدود في الجنوب الاردني واكثر من عالم
من مشكله قله الامطار وما تلاها من جفاف
الا ان المنخفض الاخير اعاد نسبه تخزين
المياه فيه الى ما يقارب 80% من طاقته
الاستيعابيه له طول المطر وصل الى حوالي
38.5% من المعدل السنوي العام للهطول
المطر اللي هو 8-1 بالعشره مليار متر مكعب
وهو افضل مما قلنا عليه العام الماضي
ويشكل من العام الماضي كاملا 49.5% فهذه
نسبه جيده وضعوا مره على البلاد اخذت منه
السدود الحصه الاكبر العام الماضي ومع
عوده المياه الى الس بكميات لم تصل ربما
لحل الازمه المائيه في البلاد حلول اخرى
فرضت نفسها كمشاريع الحصاد المائيه من
خلال جمع المهدور من مياه الامطار في حفر
مجهزه باتت فرصه يستثمرها اصحاب القطاع
الزراعي ومربوا المواشي
اكثر من 26 حفره وسدا ترابيا مهمتها تجميع
مياه الامطار في المناطق الاكثر تاثرا
بالجفاف اضافه لامداد الابار الجوفيه من
مياهها عبر ما يعرف بشحن المياه الجوفيه
تغير مناخ الان يتم مجابهته بزياده
الحصائد المائي والحفائر الترابيه والسدود
وايضا زياده الغطاء النباتي بزياده
الغابات الموجوده على اطراف هذه الحفار
يتم استثمارها بالمناطق التي يمكن انك
تزيد الغطاء النباتي فيها بحيث انك تكافح
موضوع التغير المناخي الخضرا بندوره خيار
همم كل الخضار هذه الصيفيه هذه كلها
نستفيد منها نستفيد منها للحلال ونستفيد
منها للبشره ونبيع
بين ابتلاء السدود ونجاح مشاريع الحصاد
المائيه يبقى الرهان وعلى موسم مطري يتمنى
الجميع ان ينتهي بافره الامطار كما كانت
بدايته من محافظه الكرك جنوب العاصمه عمان
عماد العضيله العربيه
تقدم الشركه ايسا اليابانيه للادويه بطلب
للحصول على موافقه الجهات التنظيميه على
عقار لكان ماب لعلاج مرض الزهايمر وذلك
بعد ما حصل هذا العقار على الموافقه
الامريكيه العقار طورته شركه ايسا
اليابانيه بالتعاون مع شركه بيوجين
الامريكيه وتبلغ كلفه العلاج السنوي اكثر
من 26,000$ ونجح العقار خلال التجاريريه
في ابطائي التداول المعرفي والوظيفي لدى
المصابين بالمراحل المبكره من المرض بنسبه
27%
مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليات تعويم السفينه الجانحه في مضيق
البوسفور كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا فان السلطات
التركيه اعلنت تعليق حركه السفن في مضيق
البوسفور بعد ان جنحت هذه السفينه وهي
السفينه شحن كانت محفره من اوكرانيا الى
اسطنبول المديريه العامه ايضا للسلامه
الساحليه في تركيا قالت في بيان ان سفينه
الشحن واسمها ام كي كي 1 والتي يبلغ طولها
142 مترا جناحت قباله ساحل بيكوز في مدينه
اسطنبول اشارت ايضا الى انه تم ارساله فرق
الانقاذ وقاطرات السحب الى مكان الحائط
مازلنا معكم اذا مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه
الصور المباشره لعمليه تعويم السفينه
الجارحه في مضيق البسفور
مشاهدينا بقينا نذكره بابرز العناوين
توقف حركه السفن في مضيق البسفور بعد جنوب
سفينه القادمه من اوكرانيا ومساع
الاستئناف الملاحه
العثور على الصندوق الاسود للطائره
النيفالي المنكوبه لكن لا امال في وجود
نجيب
تظاهرات مرتقبه لايرانيين امام البرلمان
الاوروبي لتصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
ارهابيه
روسيه تعلن اسقاط مسيره فوق ميناء في
القمه وبدء مناورات المشتركه روسيه بلا
روسيا في مسك
نهايته هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا
شكرا لحسن المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]